you're listening to the economist asks
i'm anne mcelvoy
and this week we're asking is the battle
to conquer coronavirus
like a war armed forces have been
mobilized to fight a new global enemy
unlike any faced in modern times yet as
armies grapple with the pandemic on the
ground
geopolitical jostling continues unabated
my guest is the head of the british
armed forces
general cynic carter chief of the
defence staff
he's the most senior uniformed military
adviser to the government
he served in germany during the cold war
during the sectarian conflict in
northern ireland too
and commanded troops in bosnia and
kosovo as well as tours in iraq and
afghanistan
where he was deputy commander of the
nato mission
general cynic carter welcome to the
economist asks no thanks ann it's very
good to be with you
you've described the army's mobilization
against
coronavirus in the uk as
the single greatest logistical challenge
of your career and that's a career
that's been spent in
incredibly difficult theaters of warfare
so
give us a sense if you could of the
scale and nature of this challenge and
why it's different
um well i think it's different because
um so much of the way that
government is organized is on the basis
of being as efficient as possible
and therefore all of our logistic
systems uh tend to be what they call
leaned out
so when you're confronted by something
where you have to have a massive
increase in the demand signal for
customers whether that's hospitals or
individual practices in the case of the
nhs that of course is a massive
expansion of the logistic effort and
when you then consider that you've got
to have
much more complicated supply chains that
make all of that happen
that's why i described it as being the
single greatest logistic challenge that
i've come across
in my career and that includes both gulf
wars you're one of the few people who've
seen the five eye security
report that suggested china covered up
this
outbreak and indeed may have made it
worse by its early lack of cooperation
what do you conclude from the reports
that you're seeing
um i mean i think it's unhelpful at this
stage to have a witch hunt
um i think what we've got to focus on is
how we prevent this from happening in
the future ultimately we need to be able
to work together to solve the problem
a witch hunt is not going to exactly
encourage teamwork i mean a witch hunt
suggests that
there's nothing to find i mean witch
hunt is a phrase used when one doesn't
particularly want to go and find
something well personally
i've seen no evidence of this being a
deliberate act by anybody
or it coming from a particular mistake
from anywhere either so when mike pompeo
says there's evidence
enormous evidence he said the virus
initiated wuhan institute of virology
and the us intelligence community would
appear to be quite divided on this issue
you know one of the things that you have
to do i suppose
is kind of weigh up different forms of
intelligence and come to come to your
own view i know you're not exactly going
to read out a
classified intel sadly for us on the
show
but but yeah i don't put you in an
impossible position on that general but
what
where do you come down on that kind of
question
my perspective is that um i have
personally seen no evidence that it
emerges from any deliberate act or
mistake by any government
um and my own view is that what you've
now got to do is to work out
globally how we prevent this sort of
thing from happening again
and how would you do that it comes down
to a global conversation and those
at the moment tend to be had probably in
un circumstances or through the g20 or
whatever it might be
but at the end of the day i think that's
got to be the conversation and we've had
five pandemics now since the year 2000.
they've all emerged from different
places um and those
pandemics we are going to get worse
unless we find a way of
genuinely resolving them what about
disinformation and misinformation
about the virus i think you mentioned at
a
daily briefing that you gave not long
ago the
so-called 77 brigade is working with the
cabinet officer with the heart of
of government to help quash rumors about
misinformation this is something
not peculiar to the uk a a lot of
concern about
disinformation and misinformation in the
united states and in the other
democracies how practical is it
to combat that kind of threat given that
it's very disaggregated it's simply
about where people go
to get information so it may sound a bit
pedantic but i think you have to
distinguish between disinformation
and misinformation and of course
misinformation will come from you know
people who
may have got scams going conspiracy
theorists and jokers and all the rest of
it
and a lot of what our 77 brigade has
been doing in support of the cabinet
office
has been after misinformation uh and
finding misinformation and then getting
other parts of government or indeed the
media to call them out
but but that in itself sounds i mean to
some people that would sound like
something one that won't be very much
aware that something called the 77
brigade and what it does
and it does sound quite secretive can
you throw a bit of light on how it works
it is something that we created um not
for this purpose
uh it's something that was created for
battlefields um when of course
increasingly
uh the information dimension of um you
know what we do on battlefields is
becoming really important
and essentially we would use it an
environment like say afghanistan
to be able to connect to the population
or indeed to the outside world
to bring get the message across that
perhaps one might in the past have
described as propaganda but is actually
much more about getting to the truth of
things
so would you get involved in something
like the
disinformation uh about 5g
and the allegations floating around
quite prolifically on social media that
that it had something to do with the
outbreak of coronavirus in the uk it'd
be much more about
um identifying that there was a story
going on and then
giving it to others at the political
level to sort out for themselves would
be inappropriate for
um the military to be involved in um
propaganda at home if you if you could
put it like that um
you know capers it was designed for the
battlefield you know has
advantages at this level but that's not
the way we're going to use it it's about
um identifying challenges for others to
solve
you're very closely involved in debates
about the future
of nato and how it it should work in
future as a defensive alliance but even
that kind of argument
has been reshaped by the pandemic you
know we
we've seen countries collaborating on
joint vaccine funding pledges absolutely
huge
eight billion dollar commitment
organized by the european union in this
case with pledges from japan canada
australia but the us was absent and i
guess that
brings us to the question of where we
see
the role of the united states in
this persistent defense alliance of nato
and what will
mean for the future there's been
absolutely no question of the us being
right at the heart of all of the nato
activity that we've been involved in
over the last um
two to three years um and you know they
were very much at the heart of the new
nato military strategy that was
published last year
and they're very much at the heart of
the work that we're now doing to take
the nato military strategy to its next
level
so i i don't see any evidence of doing
anything different there
what do you expect then from the
european union or from
our allies in europe particularly our
big traditional military ally
is france but also to an extent to
germany and i know you've worked very
very hard on that sort of anglo german
relationship in the military sphere
and yet there's a sense that it is it's
piecemeal isn't it it's it's every
country for itself well i
mean i think there have been some
indications for people working together
i mean the prime minister
chaired a global meeting uh to talk
about the vaccine
um and you know finding a vaccine is
something that is going to require
all of us to put our shoulders to the
wheel i also think we're beginning to
care less about
thinking about vulnerable countries um
because you know
we're not going to be able to solve a
problem of all the vulnerable countries
in particularly the developing
world unless we do that on a team basis
and i'm absolutely certain that you know
we share common ground with for example
germany and france in trying to get
after that
and we will do it in a united way
because these vulnerable countries will
remember who helped them
in times of crisis what about the
response of
donald trump it somewhat veers from the
desultory
to uh sometimes perhaps to the eccentric
in his own response and suggestions
about how to deal with coronavirus does
that worry you
no i'm not sure it does i mean i think
when you talk to the american machine
and everything that's happening with the
united states you know we we we um
we still continue to have the sorts of
conversations that i think you'd hope
would be had about how we are
going to get after this challenge but it
must be
at some level as you have deep military
ties with the us
but we have also seen a pretty
disaggregated response
in the us and this is obviously such a
major play in any argument or any debate
about where the international system
goes next so when you are sitting down
there with your opposite number
with the senior most senior commanders
in the u.s what are you asking for
i'm regularly talking to my u.s opposite
number at the moment mark milley
the chairman of the u.s joint chiefs of
staff you know we have a close
relationship as to our militaries
and um he sees it in much the same way i
do that you know this is going to be a
problem that is a global problem that
needs to be solved
globally uh and you know he sees it very
much from a perspective of you know what
the us can do to lead
um the western world through this so i'm
i'm you know i'm confident from a
military perspective
um he sees it in exactly the same way
that i've been describing it
what impact would you say the pandemic
is having in terms of
the global outlook what we might call
bad or dangerous actors you
gave an interview i think towards back
end of last year emphasizing
how much cyber activity was seeing
hostile cyber activity
from russia they think there was a a
recent
um event on about march the 11th when
nato jets had to scramble to intercept
russian planes
off the coasts of ireland and scotland
how frequently is this sort of thing
going on
well i think you know sort of every
every week to two weeks um i mean i
don't see any
diminution in the in the terms of
activity that we've seen over the last
year and a half to two years at all
um but then equally we're also doing
what we do
and we've got a an operation come
exercise going on
uh off the northern coast of norway at
the moment um and we've still got people
exercising in parts of europe
particularly in estonia where we have a
battle group at the moment
so i mean you know neither are the
russians or for that matter
nato are really taking their foot off
the gas in general terms i think the
the level of effort and activity is you
know not far off what we
normally would expect to see and the
national cyber security center
here in the uk uh advised recently i
said jointly with
the department of homeland security in
the u.s over so-called advanced
persistent
threat uh actors groups exploiting the
pandemic to get access to information
to intellectual property to targeting
pharmaceutical companies
uh among others is this something that
you're seeing arising specifically
related to the context we're in of
uh covert 19 where are the threats
mainly coming from i think they come
from the the usual places
um that we have noticed in the past um
and of course you know way where
where you have a crisis that's a bit
mysterious to to those of us who are not
sitting around the
table with the joint chiefs of staff
well i think it's more of our
authoritarian political opponents
who want to have a go at us um and you
know you know one of the things that's
playing out isn't it with this
coronavirus thing is there's a bit of a
a bit of a competition isn't that
between whether authoritarian is the
right answer or all the sort of
western um liberal democratic ideals
that we stand for is going to be the
best way of solving this problem
and and of course what disinformation
does doesn't it is to try to
play to existing divides and i think
that's what you see playing out here
and more so in the virus than previously
or at about the same level
i uh i don't have the evidence say it
it's greater but i think
you know the virus does force people
perhaps to as we you and i are now doing
as it were to be at home doing things uh
in a digital way so the answer is that
you know it is it is an obvious
opportunity for those who would continue
to wish to make
mischief and spread disinformation let's
look to uh what this means for the
so-called global ceasefire the u.n
uh was bidding for that and suggesting
that that
would be one positive response to the
coronavirus pandemic
uh globally the us uh counted that it
could restrict the pursuit of
terrorists in iraq what is your view of
the usefulness
of this rather sweeping idea of a global
ceasefire in the main conflicts that are
haunting the world
i mean the challenge of course is that
you know that's something that would
probably be
might be signed up to states some states
but of course
so much of the challenges in this world
are from non-state actors
and the extent to which daish or its
affiliated organizations
isis as others prefer to call it um are
going to sign up to ceasefire i remain
doubtful about
i'm certain they might have to limit
some of their activities because the
virus will be a problem for them in
the same way it is for everybody else
but i don't see any uh diminution in
their
ambition certainly to continue to make
mischief
general cynic carter thank you very much
for joining us no thanks ann very much
this interview is from our show the
economist asks
and every week we publish a new episode
in which we interview
key figures in world events the link
opposite will take you to a page
with all of our previous episodes thanks
for watching